Film Courage: Writing style versus voice?
What are the differences?
Jennifer Brody: Well I always talk about what
is the difference between character and voice.
So character is someone in a story and they
are going to have a voice which is going to
be the way they talk but then the over-arching
voice of the story is more about the way it
is told like the style and voice in terms
of the writing an sometimes that is also the
characters voice, especially if you’re writing
in first-person or a third-person clothes,
because you are trying to encapsulate what
they see and feel….what was the other thing
you asked about?
Film Courage: Oh…yes…writing style?
Jennifer Brody: Style!
Yes, they kind of overlap a little bit.
I mean the style of writing and the voice…voice
is really trying to capture the feeling of
the narrator’s voice or the character’s
voice or the way that the story is told.
The style of it (I guess) would be more like
the way that you’re writing the book.
But there’s a lot of overlap between all
three of those areas.
When you pick up a book that has really strong
voice, you are usually hearing the character
and hearing the world.
And every book exists within its on world
even books that aren’t specifically sci-fi
fantasy.
You’re still crafting a world even if it’s
something like a thriller, it has a feel and
an internal logic to the world and it’s
not necessarily the real world, even.
if it’s a contemporary story.
Something like GONE GIRL exists in its own
real world.
I don’t think those people exist in the
Those characters to me are very unrealistic
in a lot of respects, but in the world of
that story they are all like that.
And so I don’t think that is a real world
thing, even if it takes place in the here
and now.
But there is a specific way that she (Author
Gillian Flynn) writes her stories and that
she transports you into them.
Film Courage: Hooking in the reader from the
beginning?
I’m sure it’s going to vary especially
within the YA world and the different genres
that there are whether it’s fiction, steampunk,
whatever it may be.
Jennifer Brody: Oh yeah!
Steampunk, what fun!
I think hooking the reading is just so important
regardless of what you’re writing.
I just think for me, if I’m not really feeling
a book (and I don’t put a lot of books down)
but 50-100 pages is a long time and if I’m
not feeling it and you’d be surprised how
many books don’t really work on that level,
I may not finish it.
And especially if you’re dealing with more
commercial genres it becomes even more important,
younger readers, I think it becomes even more
important.
That said I don’t think you need to rush
or sacrifice the storytelling to make it so
hooky.
In a certain respect I personally wouldn't
want to do that but I think getting into the
story right away, having something exciting
happen in the beginning.
In my book I chose to write a prologue that
showed kind of what happened before when the
surface of the earth was destroyed so I told
it from (if you can imagine) the president’s
daughters point of view as they’re evacuating
the White House.
So young girl being evacuated and I did that
for a couple of reasons.
One was that I wanted to have something really
exciting and really relatable that happened
right off the bat because I think that this
will hook you in and make you want to read
more.
But there are other ways to hook in somebody,
like having a great character.
Having central mystery is something I teach
about a lot which is there is obviously a
mystery genre where the whole story is crafted
but that said you can have a story that has
smaller mysteries that are revealed in the
beginning of a book.
A good examples is in THE HUNGER GAMES.
They talk about the reaping which is the big
thing that happens right away in THE HUNGER
GAMES but they say the word “The Reaping”
7 or 8 times before they finally tell you
what it is and you find out fairly early in
the story but still you’re kind of reading
like “What is this?
What is this thing that is happening?
What is this big event?”
So I think that’s another way to kind of
get somebody interested and trying to figure
out what’s going on.
Film Courage: Too much conflict?
Too little conflict?
Do YA readers want more conflict than maybe
adult readers?
Jennifer Brody: I think you have more leeway
to do some bigger kind of more epic sweeping
sort of things like what you see in a STAR
WARS movie, for example.
You know too little conflict in any story
or too little tension and the story is going
to be really boring and nobody is going to
be interested.
I think you need to have conflict and tension
almost if not in every scene of your book
but pretty much in every scene, even scenes
that are character driven.
I always think you want to look for how can
you ramp up the tension in that, even if it’s
just a dialogue exchange you try to have moments
that are ratcheting up the tension.
So a good example of that is something like
in the beginning of THE SHINING (the movie).
I also love the book, but the film there’s
a scene where it’s the mom talking to Child
Protective Services.
So you’re learning information about the
fact that the father may have been abusive
toward the son.
But it’s just a dialogue seen but the the
whole time she is smoking a cigarette and
the ash just gets longer and longer and you’re
like “Oh my God!
Ash your cigarette!”
You get so tense for her.
You’re like “It’s going to fall all
over you!”
And she doesn’t and it’s somehow this
genius way of just keeping tension.
So there’s always little things you can
look at in a scene to kind of keep the tension
going and then obviously there are big conflict
scenes where there is a fight or actually
something major happens or a major obstacle
but I think throughout a story, that’s what
keeps you reading and people would be like
“Oh, it’s getting worse.
It’s getting so much worse for these characters.”
Or even like a book series like Game of Thrones,
you’re like “Oh, my God!
Things are still happening and happening.”
But it’s like, that is what keeps the story
going.
A story about conflict is a really boring
story.
I think Kurt Vonnegut famously said make great
characters and then make bad things happen
to them.
Film Courage: If a book is not part of a series,
let’s suppose it’s just going to be a
standalone book, is the protagonist always
victorious in the end?
Jennifer Brody: No and you see that a lot
(my book is considered dystopian), especially
in dystopian series where a lot of times they’re
not victorious and I when I teach structure
I talk about that where there is going to
be a moment at the end of the story where
a character makes a decision.
They need to make a choice that really reveals
their moral caliber, but that doesn’t mean
that the choice they make has to be the right
one.
A good example is Romeo and Juliet, right?
Romeo does make a choice at the end and it’s
a terrible choice and it ends tragically for
him.
He made the wrong decision.
So no…it doesn’t always have to result
in a happy ending and I think some of the
greatest stories sometimes don’t.
That said, I think if you are going to go
for a really kind of…I won’t call it a
negative ending but an ending where the protagonist
is not victorious it makes your job so much
harder in a lot of ways.
I think you really need to pull that off because
your readers are probably going to be a little
bit mad at you to a certain extent.
So I think it needs to have a compelling reason
why to have that sort of ending or a compelling
reason why you wanted to do that for your
story because we’ve all been there where
we’ve seen something with an ending where
we go “Wow!
That was really dark.”
And sometimes I love it and even in films
where classically a lot that is focus-group
tested out of the film, but films like I AM
LEGEND or the third TERMINATOR film where
something really dark happens at the end but
then it’s awesome.
And of course if you get into more like horror
movies and things like that, then it’s almost
expected because a lot of times in those,
the antagonists becomes the protagonist.
So when we’re watching NIGHTMARE ON ELM
STREET, right..okay..maybe originally we were
rooting for Johnny Depp and the teens.
But at a certain point Freddy is who we are
rooting for.
At a certain point you’re showing up at
these films to see Michael Myers or Leatherface
or Pinhead (I’m a huge HELLRAISER fan).
But you’re showing up for them more so almost
then who are the classic protagonist and you
kind of want to see them win in the end and
boy would we be upset if Freddy was gone at
the end.
I know Freddy’s done at the end of the movie
but he’s not really gone.
Question for the Viewers: What’s your favorite
author?
Why do you love them?